[Music]
that is rocker john fogarty with a more
recent rendition of his 1969 song
fortunate son i know you know it he
originally performed that with credence
clearwater
revival and those are his kids there
with him in this rendition of it how
about that
it became an anthem at a very tumultuous
time for this country and he's now got a
new song
for this difficult moment our series a
more perfect union aims to show
that what unites us as americans is far
greater than what divides us
an idea that's been tested lately our
jimmy yuka spoke to fogerty in los
angeles
at 75 john fogerty is once again using
his distinctive voice in pursuit of
social justice
i can't breathe with a career spanning
some
50 years and sales topping more than a
hundred million
albums fogarty calls this his most
important work and why just say there's
been no crime
[Music]
from his hilltop home he told me weeping
in the promised land was a line he wrote
some 30 years ago but now the time came
to write a full song
echoing the words weighing so heavily on
his heart
the only way we're truly going to make a
great america
is to have all americans feel like
they're included we have to
honor our diversity it's not a threat
it's our strength
do you think music can unify the country
heck yes
no matter what those pasty white guys in
the halls of
uh congress say racism is systemic
in our country the phrase i sometimes
say is
silence is racism because if you're not
doing something
you're allowing the racist to
in their win all the nurses are crying
so much sorrow so much
dying across the country at boston
medical center
the verse spotlighting healthcare heroes
spoke directly to nurse sarah demers
when i first heard it i immediately
burst into tears
it's so relevant it really hit us mr
fogerty this icon this
musical genius is mentioning us nurses
it's like
unreal
[Music]
demers had been following fogerty's
factory the online releases of new
twists
on old classics
belting out tunes with his kids the
family band came together
because of quarantine
their music inspired demers to share it
with her work family
to help lift the spirits of front line
workers
[Music]
there is a little bit of joy that would
happen when the music would come on oh
yes his music it reminds me of
the 4th of july togetherness strength
compassion something about it makes me
want to you know keep going makes me
want to save some lives
[Music]
how did i ever know i would be in a
family band i mean
it was right there all this time and i
just didn't know it demers began writing
letters to the foggerties
explaining your music gets us through
this pandemic
and pumps us up i'm in total awe of
especially the nurses
the ones that are saving our life and
shining a light
down a very long tunnel that we hope to
get
to the end of the fogarty family relies
on their faith to get through the
darkest of days
that's why spreading light to others
struggling is a passion project
let's give this to sarah oh that's a
great idea
maybe she can have a little bit of fun
playing it
oh my god the gift of gratitude thank
you
from the bottom of my heart is now the
soundtrack of
all their lives i realize this song is a
prayer
and we'll be a better country we'll be
better people
if we accept everyone a message
in tune with the times for cbs this
morning
jamie yukis los angeles